place maintenant à l'une des vedettes
des fers 3 aquitaine et de la télévision
d'expression française tv5
cette vedette qui nous donne l'eau à la
bouche à chaque fois qu'elle apparaît
sur le petit écran s'appelle maïté lé
père lui perpétue devant les caméras de
patrice bello la tradition culinaire et
gastronomique d'aquitaine m'a été habito
rion des landes où elle tient une
auberge à l'ancien schéma it et où l'on
va retrouver ali d'helmand et jean louis
normand maïté c'est toute une histoire
écoute la star de la cuisine c'est elle
c'est maïté choc mardi 12h15 elle donne
rendez vous aux acquis tard et depuis
quelques jours aux belges au canadien
bref au pays de langue française
desservie par satellite par tv5
maïté connu internationalement c'est
fait depuis le 2 avril
et bien cette landaise de pure souche
est en cuisine depuis peu son métier
c'était annonceurs à la sncf un métier
dure fatigante sur les voies ferrées
hiver tu mettais des heures durant son
rôle avertir les ouvriers travaillant
sur la voie de l'arrivée du train j'ai
fait ça à 22h
22h je partais de mater et jusqu'au soir
avec mon mari on partait voilà toute la
journée on a fait j'ai fait les
chantiers depuis il chausse ou plus loin
jusqu'à pillot et de presse que bayonne
dax et tout ça en fait tout le parcours
ça dépend où le chantier retraité de la
sncf maïté a trouvé sa véritable
vocation la cuisine depuis six mois elle
est gérante d'un restaurant sur sa carte
caille farcie au foie gras pigeon flambé
à l'armagnac poules farcies ou faisant
au sauternes des saveurs bien gasconne
très loin de la nouvelle cuisine toute
la bande de cuisine danse mijotés et la
nouvelle cuisine qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
maintenant c'est une horreur c'est une
horreur ce même honteux parce que sa
coupe toute la cuisine on voit des
choses s'est servi dans des grandes
assiettes même par la précaution de le
passer au beurre ni rien c'est cette
affaire vous sortez les boîtes vous
décorer sa fait de la colère cd rouge et
du vert du jaune du blanc c'est très
joli mais ça n'a aucun moussette à
preuve la cuisine des mousquetaires
c'est une émission qui fait un malheur
des milliers de lettres
huit mille recettes communiquées l'année
dernière alors entre la trompette de la
sncf et les fourneaux maïté a trouvé son
bonheur régalé les gourmands se par
satellite pratiquement dans le monde
entier en je me suis laissé dire et puis
ça en certain succès alors j'en suis
quand même fier et quand même je vous
rappelle que méritée tous les mardis sur
fr3 aquitaine à 12h15 avec ses fourneaux
et ses recettes et si vous avez manqué
quelques à cet effet nous vous proposons
de les retrouver avec ses cassettes il
vous suffit de nous écrire à la cuisine
des mousquetaires fr3 aquitaine 136 rue
ernest renan 33 millions 115 bordeaux
cedex
voilà fin de